حرب تدخل يومها 300 يؤمن فيها كل من الطرف
الروسي والاوكراني انا المكاسب على الارض
ستكون اكبر من مكاسب التفاوض
وبينما يزداد الصراع الدمويه في البرد
القارس الذي لم يستطع التخفيف من حراره
الحرب يقترح المسؤولون من الطرفين خوضا
مفاوضات سلام الى ان مقابله كل منهما
لشروط الاخر لا تنم عن مدى جديه المقترح
محادثات السلام الوحيده التي جرت بين
الطرفين تسمنت مع بدايه الحرب حملت معها
شروط محايده اما اليوم فتتمتع كيا في
موقفا اقوى يدفعها لزياده مطالبها
المتوافقه مع اثار الحرب المتزايده يوما
بعد يوم ليطرح الرئيس
الاوكرانيسكي خطط السلام مجددا متضمنه 10
اولها سحب القوات الروسيه ووقف العمليات
القتاليه وضمان العداله بمحاكمه مرتكب
جرائم الحرب بالاضافه لمنع تصعيد الصراع
وتقدي امانات حول ذلك لاوكرانيا وتاكيد
انتهاء الحرب من خلال توقيع وثيقه بين
الطرفين ولما كانت محطه زابوريج النوويه
اكبر المخاوف التي قد تسببك كارثه نوويه
تطالب كيف بضمان السلامه الاشعاعيه وفي
الخطه عادته وحده الاراضي الاوكرانيه بعد
ان وقعت روسيا قرار ضم اربعه اقاليم
اوكرانيه الى اراضيها بالاضافه الى
الافراج عن السجناء وامن الطاقه والامن
الغذائي وحمايه البيئه
خطه رفضت جمله وتفصيلا بكافه بنودها وزير
الخارجيه روسي سيرجيو لم يقبل بصيغه
السلام المطروحه معتبرا انك ليست جاهزه
لخاض مفاضله سلام
نحن لا نرفض مقترحات للتوصل الى اتفاق
الدبلوماسي الشروط التي نحن مستعدون
بموجبها بدء المفاوضات معروفه جزء لا
يتجزا من هذه الشروط هو انتماء الاقاليم
الاربعه الى الاتحاد الروسي ضغوط
الاقتصاديه ونفسيه ولوجستيه يعاني منها
طرف الصراع ويزيد الشتاء الطين بالله كلها
ليست كافيه بعد لدفع الطرفين الى تقديم
بعض التنازلات الجلوس على طاوله واحده
لانهاء حرب الاستنزاف الى عمر العربيه